why do so many writers say that
outlining prevents them from being
creative
oh i think that um i think a lot of
writers feel like if they outline
to
in too detailed of a manner it will sort
of
force them into a corner when they're
writing right they'll have it too
planned out it'll take the creativity
out of it it'll take that sort of
spontaneity out of their creative
process or something like that
um
i i guess that's my that's my best guess
that's why some writers think that um
that outlining is stifling
but i actually think that outlining the
the process of outlining your story like
breaking your story and and forming the
outline can be
the creative process right like that
sort of creative process that you look
for when you're writing of discovery and
you know coming up with new ideas by
kind of juxtaposing things that you
didn't expect or whatever you can do
that in the outlining process itself
right and kind of have all of those
sparks of inspiration and creativity
while you're working in that in that
format instead of in on the page if that
makes sense
do you get a lot of pushback from
writers who don't want to outline
um
not a ton i you know i think
it's probably 50 50 in terms of writers
who like to outline or at least have
learned that it's more helpful than
than uh painful for them right and so
there are you know plenty of writers who
embrace outlining as part of their
process um and there but then there are
also writers who
um either you know feel like it's too
stifling or
um don't really have a good process and
so they
stay away from outlining or avoid it
just because they don't really
um
have like a set of steps that they can
go through that sort of reliably helps
them plan out their story right
some writers consider themselves
very intuitive writers and they're um
you know they're they're pantsers
instead of plotters um
i don't think that even those writers
that consider themselves sort of you
know intuitive writers i don't think
that i get a lot of pushback from them
usually those writers if they've been
through a few writing projects
and it's been a struggle to get all the
way through because they haven't had a
map to kind of guide them through it an
outline
they're usually not pushing back on
needing an outline they're coming to me
because they're like okay i don't really
love the outlining process but i feel
like i need one in order to help me get
through the draft right so more than
anything they're coming to me and saying
like i want to learn a little bit about
outlining that i can maybe incorporate
into my more
freeform process but that will give me
some structure to kind of help me get
through the writing you know
and you think when we tell a writer that
this outlining is so much part of the
process and really if you don't have one
it's like building a house without a
good set of sort of blueprints um that
it's like pulling back this this magical
curtain that they thought it was just
going to be this free-flowing thing and
it's almost disappointing in some way
um i hope it's not
disappointing
but
yeah i think that
maybe maybe coming up with a story in
the outlining process to some writers
feels like it's
um it's going to be too technical and
too rigid right um but
but if you you know actually start
because outlining can mean so many
different things to so many different
writers right so if you actually start
kind of working through
different steps different tools
different you know types of processes to
get get through an outline you'll see
that it's really adaptable it's you know
the process of outlining is kind of
whatever you
make of it it's whatever
helps you
prepare to write whatever it is you're
writing so
i don't know i don't think it's um
i don't think it's necessarily like
disappointing to writers but i think
that it's uh maybe eye-opening like they
they figure out kind of what outlining
really is and and what it is is specific
to them it's like whatever's going to
help you
plan enough that you have that kind of
you know structure to get through
writing your draft
is outlining a burden or is it really
part of the process well i think it's
part of the process for sure um
i hope that writers don't think of it as
a burden
because i actually think that the
outlining process is where a lot of the
fun and creativity can happen
um it's where you have the joy of sort
of
you know exploring and discovering your
story and figuring out a lot of the fun
stuff about it so i hope it doesn't feel
like a burden um i do think that
whatever sort of prep you do for your
story is part of your own personal
process and
you know whether you are a very detailed
outliner or more of just a like sort of
broad broad strokes i got to figure out
kind of the general shape of my story i
consider all of that sort of the
pre-writing or outlining process so
whatever it is for you is is part of the
process for you you know
why is it hard for writers who think
they have a great idea to actually start
writing their ideas down
and begin the writing process
that's a good question i'm sure there
are a lot of different answers to this
question just depending on the writer
um i think part of it is probably
fear right and that fear can also be
different for different writers too
before you write anything down i think
an idea can feel
complete and perfect in your head
and then when you sit down to start
actually breaking it down or planning it
you can it can be a little um surprising
at how little you actually know about
the idea before you started to try to
write it down it felt very complete and
perfect and then when you start to write
it sometimes it can or you know start to
plan it it can feel like oh i thought i
had more of this figured out or i
thought this idea was a little bit more
solid or complete you know
so i think that can be scary and can
discourage people from
beginning the process because they feel
like they want to figure out more of it
in their head still before they start
putting anything on paper
i actually think putting it on paper is
kind of what helps you work through that
and and helps you figure out your story
so
i would encourage people to go ahead and
just start but um but yeah i think it's
probably fear you know
something can feel
very um
solid and uh makes sense
before you have to articulate it and
then when you try to articulate it it
ends up
you know sort of showing the holes in it
so
you think it's because a lot of uh
writers or quote unquote artists in
general live in their heads so much and
and it feels so real to them the story
and then when you actually say okay
let's actually see it
on the and and then it's it's you're
you're about asking them to be in
reality
yeah i'm sure that that there is truth
to that because so many writers are you
know living in their imaginations a lot
of the time um
i also think that you know
a lot of times when we get inspired by a
story idea we get really excited about
it what we're
thinking about most of the time is that
sort of act one setup portion of it it's
like the interesting situation that sort
of funny what if or what it you know how
would this happen or why would this
happen
um
and then when you sit down to kind of
figure out the whole story you realize
oh the part that got me so excited and
there's nothing wrong with it at all but
the part that gets us excited is that
set up it's that situation right that
interesting what if
and then the rest of the story is the
part that you still have to figure out
um so i think that that you know
it's not that you it's not that you came
up with an idea that you thought was
better than it actually is it's that you
came up with an idea that you have only
partially figured out
as is natural right because you came up
with that part first and then the work
of it is sort of figuring out the rest
of the story the the journey that your
character is going to go on so
right i think that's what i was feeling
i just didn't know how to put it into
words and i think that that was
that's it it's that's like the the setup
is so vivid in our minds but then
actually
having it pay off and there'll be an arc
yes and and a resolution to it i think
that's yeah yeah yeah because that's
usually that's that spark of inspiration
is we get inspired by that like oh
wouldn't it be funny if this happened or
wouldn't it be like dramatic or scary if
you know this happened
and that's all that act one setup stuff
so
what is your argument for writers to
learn an outlining process that works
for them
my argument for it uh let's see well i
mean i think that having a process will
help you right having something to fall
back on when you feel stuck or you feel
frustrated or you feel like i thought i
had the story all figured out and now
i'm realizing it's only the beginning
having a process that you have sort of
worked through before
you know that it works for you or at
least you know that you have some tools
to draw on
that can help you get unstuck i think
that's helpful helpful for any writer
right
um
and you know no matter your experience
level i think with every project there's
going to be a point where you do sort of
get stuck or you feel frustrated or it's
not going as well as you wanted it to or
you thought it would
so just having that sort of tool kit
you know which is what i think of as a
as an outlining process i think of it as
just a tool kit a bunch of tools that
you you know how to use and you can draw
on them when you need them to kind of
help you keep progressing through the
through the process you know
let's say i hire you and i have this
great screenplay and i just know this is
going to be this is going to transform
people's lives once it's on the screen
and i keep showing you draft after draft
and
your
note to me is i think we need an outline
and i'm the stubborn writer and i say no
it's going to ruin it and i you know
what what's a tough love way to sort of
be my accountability partner and say i
really think we need to go back and and
flesh this out more yeah that's i mean
that's a good question and i and i have
worked with writers who who were a
little bit resistant to you know making
big changes or something like that um
after a few drafts most writers feel
like okay i'm tired of of working
through the whole draft right so i think
the best argument for outlining if
you're in that situation is like you can
work on the story in an outline form
which is much smaller and shorter and
easier to manage than working on your
entire draft right trying to go into
your screenplay pages and make changes
sometimes is very difficult right it's
you're you're adjusting things kind of
in the
in the living document of it versus if
you make an outline even of an existing
draft
make your changes in that document
that's like you know looking at the
skeleton of the screenplay so you can
move things around more easily you're
not looking at completed scenes that
you've already fallen in love with or
lines of dialogue that you love and you
don't want to change you're looking at
it from a little bit more
i think maybe of an objective point of
view um you're looking less at the sort
of you know on the page stuff and
looking at the skeleton of your story
which i think helps people
kind of
you know have some perspective on it and
be able to see what's not working and
make changes without getting sort of
bogged down in in
all the stuff that all the work they've
already put into it that they don't want
to redo you know
i love that so fatigue i like you use
that word and so if you're seeing a
fatigued writer and let's suppose i'm
this again i'm resistant no neo we've
got to do it this way it's fantastic and
then you're seeing
the fatigue on this side that that does
sound interesting then let's look at it
and let's try to actually just shorten
it down and then work out the problems
yeah and a lot of times when i'm working
with writers i will actually outline i
will make an outline from their draft so
that i can talk about it in a way that
is
you know has that perspective and i can
say okay so if we look at act one and
see here are all the scenes
you know this is this is the issue that
we're kind of trying to address let's
look at which scenes that might be
happening in or
which scenes might be missing that so
we're not getting the information we
need or whatever the the specific issue
is you know oh i love that it's almost
the analogy of let's suppose i have this
messy closet and i can't find anything
in it and then you come and you're this
organizer and you're like okay
let's put
all of the blouses here you know and
yeah and i like that yeah that's a good
analogy yeah yeah not that i have a bad
closet yeah but this somebody that that
has that skill of being able to see the
big picture yeah
yeah and i do think too you know we get
so attached to the things that we're
writing our scripts and um our projects
and everything that
i think that sometimes it's easier to
have me outline it from their draft
versus for a couple of reasons like
sometimes writers because they've
written a whole draft they're like well
i don't want to go back and outline it
now i don't want to make an outline from
the thing i've already written right
like what good is that going to do me
so sometimes they're resistant to do it
at all but i also think that sometimes
it's easier for me to do it again
because i'm i'm objectively looking at
the script so i can look at the scene
and say well here's what i'm getting
from the scene that's what i'm going to
write down in the outline versus you
know if you're very close to your story
you know what you were trying to get
across in that scene and so you might
outline it differently than i would as
well right
so sometimes it's helpful i think if i
do the outline or if we compare outlines
and then we can see kind of where's the
discrepancy here oh this is what that
scene was meant to do from your point of
view and here's what i think it's
actually doing you know